ah whoo I'm hunting gr me like I've been
playing this game cook cook serve
delicious all week I like giving myself
like serious like risk ramp like firm at
this map it has a lot of props on it in
case you don't know like it awesome wait
am i Moxie no no I'm gonna getcha I'm
gonna getcha no she didn't she didn't
mess up as badly as I thought she did
you guys not see me because some of you
just walked through me multiple times
you've been in here same I'm a plant and
a my screen I'm in the roof above you
right now yummy oh yeah you were on the
floor
well let me just say let me just say the
Mach and Nick Roy the same thing we're
both hoax wagons beetles let's say that
if they were if they were cooking they
would have potted the shrimp ha ha
[Applause]
no [ __ ] did you find them both or is a
pun and you just missed him way to go
you just you're not gonna say yes Wow
okay wait oh my god who's this on is
this on Yami yours is on me you're in
the same place how can you both not oh
my plant and I'm looking for plans yeah
we were [ __ ] with you yeah we were do
should at least be truthful yeah we're
done why should we be truthful we always
like games nope no what I was God dang
it
oh no I'm not a table give you that but
I might God dang it please there we go
good yeah I I'm gonna do Oh someone's
been playing with these chairs quite a
considerable oh oh you give me the
questions before you kill me I saw the
same thing in that crow happened ain't
nothing wrong here
I don't waste time necro banana oh I'll
remember that for next time
I I messed up because I was what I
wanted to be and then I hid eat a drop
what I the thing that was flowing over
my head and I selected the chair and
then I was yeah
screwed someone it's it's a lot of
chairs upstairs they were like flying
everybody quiet
we're hiding okay we're gonna we're
gonna be a few this time I won't give
anyone away someone someone's probably
downstairs you'd be honest you are kind
of obvious there mark cuz you're not
aligned if you know what I mean oh it's
okay it's all right it's all right
I will hopefully played you all as well
by the way like massively I hear some
moving doors us I like to play with
doors okay can we give them a slight
clue oh man give a slight clue okay well
there's lots of mark in the restaurant
everywhere that's guys the chair or a
table perhaps you mean by the hole not
aligned which but he's in a very good
place that you won't think to look
yeah necro is something that you might
have if there was an accident
oh my god
he is a diaper good with a smiley face
on us
I am Mouse exactly I'm hiding outside he
is something that you could have with a
dessert if you miss construed the word
oh that's a clever one I like it a lot
you stay hot mean so you take away
yeah to work two different contexts yeah
he's in the opposite context but one
context you could use it for is a
dessert yeah what something miss no yes
a container for a sweet pudding
okay confused
so that's insanely opposite context
yeah the opposite context to a dessert
but he could be part of it as that is
the opposite context of a dessert it's
obvious that context it's just like a
different context I would leave now
[Laughter]
looks like it's just you and me guys
yeah I think that's why he was confused
is because mark satalia just like say it
flat-out she said there are plenty of
team in the kitchen but you didn't say
that he is in the kitchen so yeah he
could be upstairs yes
[Laughter]
I'll wait for him okay
choice that noise by me by me he's by
you how do you know that he's down there
somewhere
oh did anyone get foot anatomy
yes it was good I was in that room and
then you both went in and then I went
out finally finally I did it no don't do
that okay yeah all right over there yeah
there we go yeah I'm good I'm good I'm
gonna I'm gonna Duke you out so hard
it's gonna be the best yes I'm curious
if this is gonna work cause I was like
just standing on you joy that was great
by the way I like it
oh crap oh funk dumb look who's the a
little bottle it just ran past me yeah
here's the bottle
no one please tell us by all means okay
I think that's a good sign mushy monk
okay okay
oh no oh ma
that is me shut up no it's not is it
legal is it legal yes and what could he
be look you actually physically moved me
there I did right by downstairs I love
it down here oh yeah have you checked
everything I can honestly say and
there's no [ __ ] we're not down there
yeah the floors and I know you're down
there interest okay so I thought I got
you I got you
I'm gonna give you a quick is that when
I want to have time for another game
okay you know that song da ba dee da ba
da smell you guys good lordy Lou ever do
cavity dabba doo that's like Flintstones
hey I can't say that I'm talented
right now something that will boy
through like in lights I think it was
I'm blue if I was green I would die oh I
think that was it wasn't actually true
pretty morbid oh wow okay I just saw
someone walk out of the other basement
area
yeah again at least you didn't blow
yourself up cuz I could totally happen
them doors it mhm
I mean I want the interrogation damn it
for any questions I mean I'm in a very
conspicuous addiction I'm pretty they
open I would say ah Hugh a fountain yes
which are you that would be a Marc thing
on the floor here in a loading position
I'm think of that even know you were
there or you didn't communicate very
well with me on that position I'm
completely stuck oh so sad I don't want
to plant any ideas into your heads but I
am [ __ ] banana so yeah he doesn't
want to plant any ideas but he's a cop
[Applause]
your initial location it was pretty good
fine you're getting word because it was
too good whatever did you need to get to
the Sun so you could grow now you can
yeah I don't
[Music]
my plants failed badly oh god oh god oh
oh oh so that's good that's a sky
damn it I'm so boned oh god I'm Bo yeah
you are
I'm sorry about that oh god I'm boned
I'm so boned hey Malcolm says he's well
I don't know if he's still what he is
but he's in the basement
yeah he's yeah okay and Mark I don't
know but he Jesse's in trouble as well
I am bearable I didn't I hope it wasn't
me I probably me good fun yeah yeah
watermelon wash
oh oh oh oh odo odo odo at the main clue
you demand a clue yeah he would put all
his cards on this table like stairs and
just be a really obvious table who can't
move all along when you were getting me
a net cry let's put it that way yeah
Oh pretty much Oh marks the last one
left yes
so definitely something big I couldn't
possibly be lying no way still mess up
or is he I'd say well you are my must oh
okay oh that's upstairs go go go go no
one's been in my area no one has been in
the area no one has been in my area this
is very strange you'd be on the same
floor as him just not the area yeah I'm
looking around cold cold cold cold cold
cold thank you
has anyone area yet no honestly no no
one's been near me yet yeah if you were
here where I am you'd see me it's a big
issue let's put it that way a big she is
D Magazine big issue how has no one been
where I've been everywhere on that
happen everywhere I'm so composed wow
this is I think I've even got my
teammates forth I know what you are dude
I'm just like double birthing good
that's the closest you've been Hey
there's no one has been where you are
[Music]
I'm stuck
did you me or something i jus tip yeah
yeah why did you do that but ya gotta go
yeah
[Music]
no idea so close guys you stick an axe
over there